as complex as the microbiome is it can
be simplified by understanding those
those chemicals and this whole science
of
metabolomics which is a study of
studying these metabolites they are
essentially mini pharmacies they are
taking the food as their consumables and
pumping out all kinds of chemicals that
are unique to us and our system we are
converting one set of chemicals as food
by our microbes into these other
chemicals which have massive effects on
our immune system our brains and our
bodies and our health we're just really
scraping the surface of what we know
about these things but they have huge
potential in all kinds of areas not just
in nutrition but in you know Pharmacy
and fighting disease and everything else
because of this all these incredible
chemicals they're producing all the time
that we co-evolved with